ふふｗｗ
ふざけやがってｗ
えー
がおおおおおおん(恐竜の真似)
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
えーはじめアミューズメントパークには
実は隠れた場所に色んな棚があるんです
ここもその一つ
もうここに住み始めて3年ぐらい経ってるんで
結構物がめちゃくちゃ多くて
要らない物とかって棚とかに入れるんですよ
僕結構断捨離で物を捨てちゃうんで
捨てないってなるとなかなかレアなんすよ多分
こん中には多分「え、そんなのまで入れちゃう？」みたいな物が入ってたり
なんか僕が今見て喜べる物が入っている気がするんです今日
なかなかこういう棚を開ける機会とかないんでちょっと今回は
この棚の中をちょっと全部見ていこうかなと思っております
というわけで今日の動画は
そんだけ
いやいやいや待ってください
待ってくださいよ
俺の予想が正しければ多分すごいレアな物とか
多分お宝的な物が出てくると思ってるんで
まぁそこも含めて今日の見どころかな
だってもう3年住んでっかんね
ってかもう大切な物ばっかり入れてる気がするんで
開けます
はい
あー
おー
まぁまぁぱっと見ちょっとまぁやや汚いくらいですかね
まぁまぁまぁ安心せい
きっとこの中には驚くような宝物が入っていること間違い無いと思ってます
だって俺さ本当すごい断捨離なんすよね
要らない物片っ端から捨てるんで
捨てずにとっておくってことは
なかなかすげー物が入っていると思うんすよ
折り紙です
いや、もっとやばいのが入っていますよ
あーネクタイ
あぁ七つの大罪
コンセント
あっあっあっ
ポッ拳だ
やべーSwitchのポッ拳が入ってる
これ多分誕生日にあのあれだたかちゃんからもらったやつだ
あーモンハン
あーでも基本的にはゴミ系が多いな
あーっ！あっあ！！あ！！！
やばい俺これ探してたレンズカバーだ
一眼のレンズカバーなくて超困ってたんすよ
あれ？でもカメラも無くしたんで別にいいっす
うわっ！あっ！
はっ！！！
こじはるの写真集だ
うわああああ
お〜お〜おぅ
あー良かった見つかって
俺これたまーに定期的に読まないと生きていけない気がするんだよな
結局なんかよくわかんないのが多いんすよね
な、なん、なんだこれ　なんぞなんぞ
ふっ　なん、なんで俺こんな買ってんだよ
紙をこうやって切る機械みたいなやつっすね
おーなんかノート類だ
English うわーなんかちゃんと勉強してた
あるんですけどすごいなんか勉強していたなーって思います
あーやっぱねやる時はやるんすよ
やる時はやる男だったんすね
なんか青いスーツです
着ることがなかったやつ
あ！まさやから借りてたバイオハザード
健康診断のやつですね
カメラのゴミとかも入ってます
あっ！あっ！！PS vitaだ
やばっ色、色もやばっPS vitaやったぁ
PS vitaまじどこ行ったかと思ってたら
こんな場所にあったのか
あ、デジモンやってたんだなぁ
良かった〜こういうの無くなるんすよね
なんかゲーム機って結構割と無くなりがちな気がするんですよね
良かった見つかって
これなんか動画で使ったことあるな
俺の記憶が正しければ動画で使ってた気がします
俺こそが世界的に有名なファッションデザイナー
足腰弱男だ
紙兎ロペのカレンダー2016年だ
ちょっとどんどん見てきます
カエルの…お手紙
もいもいまじ汚い汚いグロいグロい
ゴキブリのおもちゃです
あぶねー
本棚見ると結構英語の勉強してるんすよね
英語系がすごい多い気がします
重い…
ラブライブのほのかちゃんのカードが入っています
ん〜〜
やべなんか大学時代のものが多いっすねー
TOEIC対策ノート
白紙だ何にも対策してねー
じゃ2段目いきます
おーアキラ先輩じゃないっすか
おいお前っさー　お前ほんとっ　チッ
お前使えｗねぇーなぁ
うわっ！うわあああ！
うわもうなんだこれ、なんのスピーカーだ
なんかスピーカー置いてあります
普通に使いたいとこではあるな
うぁ〜あ！なんで！！
あーここら辺結構ゲームゾーンですね
ARMSとかのポケモン一式とか置いてあります
まとめてゲーム系入れたんだなこれ多分
これゲーム…
うわぁーうぉっうっ
うわー待ってびっくりした
えー待ってなにこれ怖い怖い怖い怖い
すいませんちょっと閲覧注意でいいですか？
この、この、この、これ何？これ何？
えーなんか生き物のフンとかじゃないよね？
大丈夫だよね？え、待ってほんとに怖い
いや多分このムカデが、のなんかあｒだ
手足がち、ち、ち、千切れたやつだよ多分
うわー待って一気に怖くなっちゃった
もう最悪だよ
すいませんグロいんで隠させていただきます
いやこの棚が一番楽しみですね
はいモンハン、どう森
出たーMOTHER２大好きなんすよね
MOTHER２の手帳が入ってます
これめっちゃレアで高いんですよね確か
俺何を思ってたんだろうなんか
おでんのキーホルダーをめちゃくちゃ買ってました
これは…
待ってくださいよ
待ってくれ…俺にそういう趣味はねー
うわっWiiだWii 超懐かしい
あ！デジヴァイスだ
あのデジモンを進化させるやつです
あ、やっぱゲーム系がすごい多いっすねやっぱり
輪ゴム　輪ゴム
あー動画で使ったやつ懐い
パウエル(?)あれをもうめちゃくちゃ
アニメが好きすぎてもうアニメのばっかり買っちゃってたっていう時期がありまして
ア愚問　あーとは多分そんな取り上げるものがないはずだと思います
っしゃー次　もう一段上いきます
あっ最近買ったどせいさんです　可愛いでしょ
あーもうここら辺もう自分のグッズかな
オレの目覚まし時計
ポケモンの攻略本っす
これあれ買うだけでマスターボールもらえるんでまじで買いました
うわあああびっくりした！！
うわぁもう最悪だ
はぁ　死ぬかと思った今
ふざけんなよ
めっちゃ中にヘビが入っているんですけど
多分俺なんだろうけどねやった人は
もうやだー
怖いのやだー怖いのやだー！
そうだあとVジャンプめっちゃ僕買うんすよ
おまけでカードがついてくるんで
FINALFANTASY
なんで買ったんっていうくらいたくさんのワゴム
ドミネーター：執行対象デス
はじめ：なくしたと思ってたぜ
ドミネーター：セーフティーヲ解除
うわやばいCLANNADの風子ちゃん
待ってこれやばいぞやばいぞこれ
これやばい多分ふら、くわっ、え　これやばい
これ多分すげーレアだった気がすんだよなぁ　ポイ
こんなもんかしらねーあとはそんなに…
ああぁ？あああああああ！
うええええええええええ
おい爆竹めっちゃ入ってんじゃん
いやそれにしても爆竹の数やばいな
結構な爆竹の数ありますよ
俺どこからこんなの見つけてきたんだよ
こん中はこんなもんでございます
次がラスト　うっわぁ〜
ラストがやばいっすね
多分ほぼね遊戯王だと思うんすよ
上から取ってって遊戯王以外の物があったら反応します
ちょっともう原則としてほぼ遊戯王なんすよね
いやよくねぇーよ
うわっ！やば！これやばいもう
ベイブレードの昔のやつです
中古屋さんで売っててレアすぎて買っちゃいました確か
うわすごーいなんかおしゃれなクルトガ
AirPods
あーラブライブだー
すげーこんなキングスライムこんなとこに入っていたのか
あ〜あ〜あ〜デュエルディスクだ
やばいもうぱっと見30冊くらいはあるVジャンプが
あとはもう結局遊戯王関係ですね
いやいや買いすぎだよ遊戯王ほんとに
はぁい　って感じすかね
片付けたくなーい
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】